people they've caught in the last few
days or over there in sector three or
monument three
have been on the uh terror watch list
individuals that they have on the watch
list for terrorism
are now starting to exploit the southern
border
we need to wake up we need to understand
listen mr
president biden you're an okay guy why
don't you just admit you made a mistake
with this policy
and go back to the way it was the door
should not be open and we should have
immigration the right way that he said
that he's a republican i like that he
said you're
you know you seem like a okay guy a good
guy just take the introduction
right right and how about this didn't he
tell us last week when i make a mistake
i will tell you i made a mistake
well this is your opportunity mr
president the remaining mexico policy
needs to remain i don't think they want
to buy into it anymore because it's a
little ticked off
and number two is uh the proposition 42
has to get back enacted
let's bring in dan bongino fox news
contributor so dan what are the odds the
president's going to say i made a
mistake
like that robert downey jr movie less
than zero that was a movie right
if i remember for ls 80s kids out there
there is it's not going to happen of
course it isn't going to happen because
that would require guts
and i'm sorry but biden doesn't have
guts he doesn't have the guts to stand
up to the
insane now radical left he doesn't have
the guts to do
i mean listen guys the country's falling
apart right now okay
i'm really sorry but we're in the middle
of a catastrophic debt crisis we've
opened our southern border
right now we have an economy that's
still struggling to get out of the
doldrums from this pandemic
we have a biden right as we are trying
to get out of this
collapse i know this is immigration but
if you'll just allow me for a second
right as we're getting out of it they
have this genius idea
these dunces in washington dc get a lot
of this we're gonna give you guys
stimulus checks for 1400
and then simultaneously tax it all away
and take it all back
these are the how did we get 535 of the
dumbest people in america
to all get elected to office in d.c at
the washington
and washington dc at the same time how
did we do
who is the genius who's sitting in a
board room in washington dc
somewhere or up on capitol hill and i've
got a better idea
as we're giving people money to tax it
back let's just
open the southern border in the middle
of a pandemic
because this is a spectacular idea
for american prosperity there is nothing
better than this
and then somewhat does anyone in that
room anyone say
folks i have a question i'm going to
raise my hand
not only are we in the middle of
pandemic but you know we have this whole
national security thing we've been
talking about
where we should probably vet people
coming into the country and everybody's
like
look at this idiot national security
pandemic
borders who needs any of that crap i
mean we're watching the collapse of the
greatest country
in the history of humankind and again
535 of the dumbest people
humanity has ever offered up are all
sitting in dc
right now lording over the entire
process
like it's like the hobbit lord of the
rings how did we elect such morons
is this hard we have a border is there a
country in the history of humankind
that didn't have a border you know what
you have if you don't have a border
you have a land mass you have a
suggestion
you don't have a country just close the
border and say hey you want to come in
there's the door there's this thing
called the process
sorry guys but my wife did it it's it's
not hard
you go in you say my wife said how did
you i'm
not i gotta i got one more because i my
wife did it's not hard
my wife and i are very smart but we
didn't invent the theory of relativity
like einstein
my wife went into the immigration place
said i'm a colombian citizen
i married this american guy he's not as
smart as me
but i'd like to be a citizen and they go
okay
here's the process and guys here's
what's even crazier
it worked my wife an american citizen
raise their head
there's a process it's not hard i am
curious
what does she say when she sees the
images because of course my heart breaks
all of our hearts break when we see
these babies coming across and
moms that are willing to travel for 22
days kevin mccarthy said he talked to
someone
they traveled for 22 days to get to the
border of course
we're human beings our hearts break for
them but i'm curious to find out how
your
what does your wife say about that
because they're not doing it the right
way
my wife and my my mother-in-law is
actually a more interesting
i'm casey i don't i mean listen i'll let
my wife do that but
she works on my show so she pretty much
like
whatever i say she goes along with on
the shows but she obviously has strong
opinions too on this but my
mother-in-law
is like i don't get this like why did i
i always think it is story right my
mother-in-law comes here from columbia
doesn't speak a word of english i don't
even know if she had ten dollars in her
wallet
she's not worth a pretty good chunk of
change because she did this crazy thing
called like working
and investing her money she she scored
on a few real estate deals
nothing huge you know not like trump
like real estate deals but she does okay
for herself and i always remember this
story
that they came here and they slept in a
one-bedroom apartment in jackson heights
and they slept kind of heads tails
you know heads tails when you only have
one mattress and and you have three kids
so you got to sleep foot to head because
there's no other room and it's a little
more convenient to pack them in like so
a working woman and you know i adore
your wife dan
i know she's i know but she says she
says she
because they slept head's tails on the
mattress lawrence
she says i heard my daughter talking
about my wife now she says i used to
hear my daughter's stomach grumbling at
night because i couldn't afford any food
wow wow you think about that think about
that
when she went through the white the
right way and did it and now you want to
understand why my mother-in-law is so
pissed off
that everyone else was like ah screw it
the right way we're just going to walk
in and do whatever we want
you understand why legal immigrants to
this country you want to know why donald
trump
did so well amongst venezuelans puerto
ricans
cubans and other hispanic immigrants
that came to this country not just cuban
americans in southern florida
maybe it's because you treat them like
idiots democrats maybe because the
people who came here
hispanic immigrants and others who are
hard working are like hey i did it the
right way this is a country of rules
and process and order and if you're not
willing to do that first
then you're not willing to be an
american because america is about law
and order and process and your first
step was to ignore that
now you understand why they're a little
pissed off that's why yeah and those
immigrants
also don't like the direction of the com
the country they don't like that
uh this social justice warrior nonsense
they don't like uh
that that were becoming more like the
countries that they fled from
they're upset and this is why the
president made some gains as you
correctly uh
said dan thanks so much for joining us
today
you got it no problem